the little things we do in the morning
afternoon or night impact our growth and
shape who we are every successful person
out there has a morning routine that
pumps them up keeping them focused start
every day with a clear purpose and I'm
sure you'll find yourself being more
productive throughout the day my routine
doesn't start in the morning it starts
in the evening how you and your day will
set a tone for the next day I have my
grateful journal and before I go to bed
every night outside aside just five
minutes to wind down reflect and ask
myself what has been the highlight of my
day
this allows me to focus on the positive
no matter how long and tougher the day
might have been and to do better the
next day
this routine has also helped me to sleep
better nowadays I don't set my alarm
clock in the morning unless I have to be
up super early way before my usual
timing and my body clock has been
accustomed to waking up at a certain
hour guys don't stare at your phone
first thing in the morning get some
sunlight in it will tell your brain it
is the start of a new day new
opportunities and it is time to hustle
and create the life you want if you can
try not to hit the snooze as that will
only create more stress to your body
first thing in the morning which can
start your day on a wrong note the first
thing I'll do once I'm up is to drink a
glass of warm lemon water on an empty
stomach I have a very sensitive stomach
and drinking lemon water every morning
helps to rehydrate my body it gets my
digestive system going and prevents
constipation if lemon is too strong for
your liking you can sweeten it with a
little bit of honey for the past several
months I dedicate 10
it's every morning for quiet time and
set my intentions for the day this
practice has helped me to deal with my
anxiety to start my day feeling calmer
and it is also my time for a little
prayer it wasn't easy to begin with as
10 minutes felt like a long time but you
can start with five minutes or even just
a couple of minutes of deep breathing
and slowly build that up it's time to
take my big babies for their morning
walk
I'll take them around my neighborhood
for about 20 to 30 minutes they always
have way too much energy and they need
lots of exercise this also gets me
moving and having them with me just
lights up my morning they bring so much
joy to my home as much as I can
I prefer exercising in the morning
because it makes me feel more energized
throughout the day it doesn't have to be
an intense workout the goal is to get
your body moving and blood flowing plus
I like to start my day knowing that I
don't have to worry about being too busy
to miss a workout it doesn't matter what
time of the day you work out what's most
important is that you find a time that
suits your lifestyle where you're more
likely to stay consistent and stick to
your routine time to feed my muscles and
have breakfast I don't like to be
fussing about in the kitchen so I like
to keep things simple I've made some
overnight oats of the day before all I
have to do is top it up with some fresh
fruits nuts and seeds at breakfast I
would also write a microd food journal
three things I'm grateful for what would
make today amazing and my affirmation
for the day for example
I'm grateful for my friends and family
my team and you I would also use this
time to make a list of what I ain't
accomplished for today this is a good
way to start my day focused and knowing
exactly what my goals are having a
physical list instead of a mental one is
more productive as it gives you the
satisfaction of crossing out something
once it's done plus it ensures that you
won't forget anything important
let's get to work what do I listen to
when I'm driving audible
I'm currently listening to the power of
vulnerability and it has helped with my
personal growth audible has an unmatched
number of audiobooks that you can listen
to on multiple devices such as your
iphone android laptop tablet iPad and
more there is speed control free
exchanges and your books are yours to
keep even if you choose to cancel your
membership I've teamed up with audible
to give you a free audiobook with a
30-day free trial go to audible.com
forward slash Joanna S or text Joanna s
- 500 - 500
again that's audible.com forward slash
Joanna S or text Joanna s - 500 - 500
more information is in the description
box below try it out if you don't like
reading or if you struggle to find the
time
try audible instead there really is no
one right way to start your day you will
have to experiment until you're formed a
morning routine that works for you that
routine should make you feel more alert
focused motivated inspired and
productive
what's your morning routine let me know
in the comments below be sure to like
this video share this video on to
motivate your friends and subscribe to
my youtube channel for a lot more
nutritional tips fitness tips workout
videos and also fitness inspiration all
the best